في روسيا اليوم، الإنتاج العسكري
مقدس
[موسيقى]
مصنع الدبابات الرئيسي الخاص به يعرض
أحدث شحناته ولمحة مصممة
عن سلالة إنتاج الإنتاج في زمن الحرب
هنا وقد تضاعف أكثر من ثلاثة أضعاف خلال
العام الماضي وفقًا لرئيس الوزراء الروسي،
ما رأيناه هو أن  لقد
كان الإنفاق العسكري أعلى بكثير مما كان
مخططًا له بالفعل لهذا العام،
ويبدو أن الإنفاق الذي كان
مخططًا له هذا العام قد
استنفد بالفعل الآن بعد أن وصلنا إلى منتصف
العام الذي خصصت فيه الميزانية الروسية
ما يقرب من 50 مليار دولار
لميزانية الدفاع.  تشير الوثيقة التي اطلعت عليها
رويترز هذا الشهر إلى أن روسيا قد
ضاعفت الآن هذا التقدير الذي
يقول الخبراء إنه قد يكون أعلى من ذلك، كما لو أنه
معبرًا عنه كنسبة مئوية
من الناتج المحلي الإجمالي، يمكن أن يتراوح بين
ثمانية وعشرة بالمائة من الناتج المحلي الإجمالي، لذا إذا
فكرنا  نسبة من الناتج المحلي الإجمالي كان من الممكن أن
تتضاعف ثلاث مرات تقريبًا، هل أنتم مندهشون
بأي شكل من الأشكال من هذا؟
لا، إنه الجواب الصادق.
كان الرئيس بوتين واضحًا جدًا في أنه
قال في ديسمبر الماضي: لا حدود
للتمويل العسكري،
ومع ذلك مع انطلاق معرض الأسلحة السنوي الروسي
هذا الشهر
بدأ التيفلون في التخلص من
الإنفاق العسكري الاقتصادي في زمن الحرب، مما
ساعد على تغذية عودة التضخم
وانخفاض الروبل، مما دفع
البنك المركزي إلى رفع سعر الفائدة بشكل طارئ ووضع حتى الروس الأكثر ولاءً
على حافة الهاوية،
كما أدى انخفاض الأسعار إلى إرسال
النفط الحيوي لروسيا و  انخفضت عائدات الغاز
في النصف الأول من هذا
العام ولكن الأسعار بدأت تتعافى
خلال الصيف. ولا تزال روسيا تجني
مبالغ ضخمة من الدولارات باليوان
واليورو من خلال تصدير الطاقة والموارد الأخرى
، وستكسب هذه
الدولارات أيضًا في المستقبل لأن
كما تعلمون، كما تعلمنا، لا يمكننا
إخراج روسيا بسهولة من أسواق النفط،
هناك تحدٍ آخر يواجه
صناعة الأسلحة الروسية.
هل تحب لعب كرة السلة؟ هذا
الفيديو التوظيفي
لمصنع طائرات الهليكوبتر في كازان،
أخبر الرئيس التنفيذي للشركة الأم
بوتين مؤخرًا أنهم بحاجة إلى ذلك.  شغل 23000 وظيفة هذا
العام، وارتفعت الأجور بالفعل 17، وهذه
قوة عمل محدودة للغاية لعدد من
الأسباب الديموغرافية ولكن أيضًا
بسبب الحرب، غادر الكثير من الناس
البلاد،
وتمت تعبئة بعض الأشخاص،
كما أدت العقوبات إلى تعطيل الإمدادات
من المكونات عالية التقنية لخبراء الأسلحة،
يقول خبراء الأسلحة إن رفع التكاليف إلى أبعد من ذلك، ومع
ذلك فقد وجد الكرملين طريقة
لتبرير هذه الحرب مع الغرب،
ولم تخف النخبة الغربية
هدفها وهو أقتبس
هزيمة روسيا الاستراتيجية لذلك
أصبح السكان الروس  لقد تم تقديمهم بهذا
الرأي، لذا فهم
يستعدون ويتوقعون أنهم
ربما سيضطرون إلى إنفاق المزيد من
الأموال لأخذ المزيد من الضربة على
مستويات المعيشة للقتال ضد مثل هذا
الخصم القوي، وهي
معركة تحدث الآن  على الخطوط الأمامية
وفي المصانع
سيباستيان سي إن إن لندن